you know I wanted a little secret and
that is the property doesn't excite me
that much property doesn't excite me
that much
I did like property but here's the thing
for me property is a vehicle and it's a
vehicle that can get you places and it's
a seraph training I don't really enjoy
training that much
I don't enjoy standing on the stage and
training it's a vehicle and it's a
vehicle to see people's results and
ultimately what it's about is it's about
change lives and it's about having a
rippling effect of people being fun and
to be free to then did that what they
love
I mean I can see her working out
formulas all day long on how to make
money and teach people how to make money
but it's not even about the money when
it's not the end goal it's about money
the vehicle properties of vehicle
teaching people using vehicle but a
vehicle for what
what is it available what's the end goal
I just I just we have some footage of a
recent crash course and we put something
together and I want you to watch this
right now because it gives me goosebumps
watching it because seeing some of the
women as well so I know I've a lot of
guy followers but we need more women on
a mission changing lives wanting to help
the needy change the world leave a
legacy so I want you to watch this this
is some of the stuff that happens our
summer events and some of our training
events and this is as a result of the
figures of learning about property of
being able to make money but this is
climbing a bit more at the end goal is
like so if you were there at the recent
crash course some of you ladies of power
power houses and I'm really excited to
be part of your journey and to see each
other in other people's lives as well
enjoy
investors you've got last night you
choose and
I'm saving money already become
compliance or convenience awesome we
actually call the agents we looked for
deals we did the numbers it is brilliant
I don't know what else I can recommend
you know for a free to the horse this is
my blue to be honest I'd recommend it to
anybody anything if you've got dream a
goal a vision it doesn't matter what job
you have or how old you are all it takes
is that first curious step be brave take
action share your story
start your party journey with us come to
the crash course we'll see you there you
[Music]
might be thinking you know what that is
so happy clappy cheesy I don't want to
do all that nonsense I just want to
learn about property
listen there's a reason you want to
learn about property there's something
bigger and at the crash course of course
you're gonna learn all about property
but also there will be opportunities for
people at times to share what their real
purpose is what their real reason is so
if you're watching this video I believe
you're here right now for a reason and
this is your time so get yourself if
you're not being come to a property
investors crash course it's free I want
to see your life changed so there's a
link right here get yourself booked on
and if you're uncomfortable or you're
worried as a successful person you need
to be comfortable getting uncomfortable
especially you ladies get booked on
can't wait to see you can't wait to see
what happens as a result have you been
at the property investors crash course